-Welcome back, everybody.
We're here with Matt Damon!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right.
Matt, your new movie "Air" is
all about Nike, Michael Jordan,
so I thought it would be fun
to play a game of basketball
with a twist.
This is Beer Pong Basketball.
Here we go.
Here's how this works.
We're gonna be throwing
these basketballs
in those giant, red cups.
If you make a shot,
your opponent chugs a beer.
First one to make three shots
wins.
Matt, you're my guest,
so why don't you go first?
-Alright, do I have to hit
a particular --
-No, any one.
[ Cheering ]
[ Audience groans ]
-Not as easy as it looks.
Let me show you how it works.
-Yeah, watch this. Oh...
Oh, yeah!
[ Applause ]
Off the board!
Off the board on that one.
Yeah!
We can go to commercial
right now if you want.
[ Crowd groans ]
-Oh, man!
-[ Chuckles ]
-I was sure that was in.
I was sure that was in.
-Me too, I was sure --
this one's --
Oh!
[ Applause ]
[ Cheering ]
♪♪
-This is brutal.
-Come on.
-Am I allowed to get it
in the same one?
[ Cheering ]
-Alright, alright.
♪♪
Alright.
-This one's for the win.
-This is for the win.
Oh, man.
-Can I get it in the one
exact one?
You called that shot.
Here we go, for the win!
Matt Damon's movie, "Air,"
is out tonight.
You can go see it in theaters.
-You're saying this
because you think
you're gonna hit the shot.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughs ]
-I'm just kidding.
I'm just kidding.
-What's up?
Boing!
[ Cheers and applause ]
There you go!
-Thanks, buddy.
-Come on, now!
Matt Damon, everybody!
"Air" is in theaters.
Aw, he's a good man.
"Air" is in theaters today.
We'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show."
Stick around.
♪♪